so i have a arbitrary inscribed
quadrilateral in this circle and what i
want to prove is that for any inscribed
quadrilateral that opposite angles are
supplementary
so when i say they're supplementary this
the measu the measure of this angle plus
the measure of this angle need to be 180
degrees the measure of this angle plus
the measure of this angle need to be 180
degrees and the way i'm going to prove
it is we're going to assume that this
the measure of this angle right over
here that this is x degrees
and so from that if we can prove that
the measure of this opposite angle is
180 minus x degrees that we've proven
that opposite angles for an arbitrary
quadrilateral that's inscribed in a
circle are supplementary because if this
is 180 minus x 180 minus x
plus x is going to be 180 degrees so i
encourage you to pause the video and see
if you can do that proof and i'll give
you a little bit of a hint it's going to
involve the measure of the arcs that the
various angles intercept
so let's think about it a little bit
this this
this this angle that has a measure of x
degrees it intercepts this arc so we see
one side of the angle
goes and intercepts the circle there the
other side
right over there and so the arc that it
intercepts
i am highlighting in yellow
i am highlighting it in yellow
trying to color it in
so there you go not a great job at
coloring it in but you get the point
that's the arc that it intercepts and
we've already learned in previous videos
that the relationship between the
between an inscribed angle the the
vertex of this angle sits on the circle
the relationship between an inscribed
angle and then the arc that it and the
measure of the arc that it intercepts is
that the measure of the inscribed angle
is half the measure of the arc that it
intercepts so this has this angle
measures x degrees then the measure of
this arc is going to be
2x
2x degrees
all right well that's kind of
interesting but let's keep going if the
measure of that arc is 2x degrees what
is the measure of this arc right over
here the arc that completes the circle
well if you go all the way around the
circle that's 360 degrees
so this blue arc that i'm showing you
right now that's going to have a measure
of 360
minus
2x
minus 2x
minus 2x degrees
360 is all the way around the blue one
is all the way around minus the the
yellow arc what you have left over if
you subtract out the yellow arc is you
have this blue arc
now what's the angle that intercepts
this blue arc
what's the inscribed angle that
intercepts this blue this blue arc right
over here
what's this angle
it's the angle that we wanted uh we
wanted to figure out in terms of x
it is
it is i'm having trouble changing colors
it is
that angle right over there notice the
two sides of of this angle they they
intercept this angle intercepts that arc
so once again the measure of an
inscribed angle is going to be half the
measure of the arc that it intercepts so
what's one-half
what is
one-half times 360 minus 2x
well one-half times 360 is 180
one-half times 2x is x
so the measure of this angle is going to
be 180 minus x degrees
180 minus x degrees and just like that
we've proven that these opposite sides
for this arbitrary inscribed
quadrilateral that they are
supplementary you add these together x
plus 180 minus x you're going to get 180
degrees so they are supplementary